احتمالان اثنان فقط الاحتمال الاول هو ان
يتخلى الديمقراطيون عن عنادهم
ويتقدمون بتعديل
للتشريع المطروح بما يسمح
بتوفير مزيد اكثر
من ال 20 مليار دولار المقرره الان لتعزيز
الحدود الجنوبيه للولايات المتحده هذا
واحد اثنين الاحتمال الثاني هو ان
ينصرم نحن في الاسبوع المقبل مجلس الشيوخ
سوف يبدا اجازه عطله اعياد الميلاد واذا
لم يتمكن مجلس الشيوخ خلال الاسبوع المقبل
من حل هذه المضله سيكون على الجميع
الانتظار الى محاولات اخرى في العام
المقبل طبعا القول ان اوكرانيا تحتاج الى
هذه المساعدات قول فيه الكثير من الصحه
ولكن ليس فيه
القدر اللازم من الياس الذي يحاول
الديمقراطيون ان يتذرعون به اوكرانيا ما
زالت لديها المساعدات وما زالت لديها
الاسلحه الكافيه على الاقل لبقائها في
المعركه حتى بدايه العام الجديد استاذ
عاطف عبد الجواد المحلل السياسي اشكرك كنت
معنا من
واشنطن